the facts don't matter in any of these
cases it did not matter what what you
said in the if the then was always going
to be the same
because the idea is if the system is bad
then anything that justifies the system
may not be that great in other words
justice is the tearing down of all of
the systems
the idea that democrats are going to
push forward and this is the next move
right is that it was never about this
particular case
it's about the broader system you'll
notice the language that is being used
by by the left today by members of the
media by
members of the democratic party is not
the system worked
usually in the aftermath of a criminal
conviction the line that you hear very
often from politicians in the media is
yes the system worked
you're not hearing that today you're
really not hearing that today but
instead what you're hearing is justice
was done there's a
major philosophical difference between
justice was done and the system worked
if you say the system worked you're
providing legitimacy to the system
life doesn't want to provide legitimacy
to the system remember remember the
system
is racist remember the system is bigoted
remember the system is the bad guy
derek chovin isn't even the bad guy
derek schoen is just the outgrowth of
the system
in a certain way a lot of folks on the
left don't even believe that derek
chovin is responsible for his own
actions because they didn't prove that
he was a racist he's just the outgrowth
of a systemically racist system
he's just a widget in the system the
system is bad so they're not saying the
system worked because that would be
lending
gravitas and legitimacy to a system they
hate instead its justice was done
when they say justice was done what they
mean is we got what we wanted the only
thing that changed yesterday because
chovin was convicted as opposed to
acquitted
is that there weren't riots because for
the left the outcome really didn't
change
right for the left it doesn't matter
what the what the
antecedent was the consequent was always
going to be the same in the if
then statement it did not matter what
what you said in the if the then was
always going to be the same
if shoving had been acquitted then the
then they would have said this
because derek joven was acquitted this
just shows that the american racial
the american justice system is racially
malevolent that america is a deeply
systematically racist place
and this requires therefore this
requires that you give us inordinate
power to reshape all the systems of
american life so as to achieve racial
equity
okay that was version number one where
chauvin was acquitted when children was
convicted here's the argument today
derek chovin was convicted and this is
just the first step to realizing that
you have to give us more power so we can
reshape the systems of american power
in line with providing a greater racial
equity it does not matter whether
chauvin was convicted or not for
purposes of the agenda
in fact it seems that there are at least
a few in the media who are kind of
unhappy that chauvin was convicted
because it seems to grant a certain
legitimacy to a justice system they
really really dislike
i mean to take one example msnbc's jason
johnson seemed pretty pissed at the
verdict yesterday he was
instead of he said i'm not going to
celebrate this verdict because it gives
legitimacy to a system that's bad
i actually always thought that he would
be found guilty because
it's sort of a cultural makeup call but
i'm not happy
i'm not pleased i don't have any sense
of satisfaction i don't think this is a
system working
i don't think this is a good thing what
this says to me
is that in order to get a nominal degree
of justice in this country
that a black man has to be murdered on
air
viewed by the entire world there have to
be a year's worth of protests
and a phalanx of other white police
officers to tell one white officer that
he was wrong
in order to get one scintilla of justice
okay that last point there
is him admitting that the jury was
pressured by the
by the millions of people in the streets
which of course is true and perfectly
obvious to anyone with a shred of common
sense it says in order to get this
conviction you needed millions of people
in the streets
okay there's a word for that and it's
mob justice okay there's a term for that
and this is not a fringe viewpoint jason
johnson's viewpoint in fact you get the
viewpoint right because the idea is if
the system is bad then anything that
justifies the system
may not be that great aoc the
irrepressible
brilliant so fresh so face
face of of justice in america alexander
ocasio-cortez who spent tens of
thousands of dollars on private security
over the course of the last few months
but you should definitely defund the
police
aoc said that this verdict should not be
a ray of hope it should just be a
reminder
that we need to completely change the
systems of american life
it's not justice and i'll explain to you
why it's not justice
it's not justice because justice
is george floyd going home tonight
to be with his family justice
is adam toledo
getting tucked in by his mom tonight
justice is
when you're pulled over they're not
being
a gun that's part of that interaction
because you have a headlight out right
all justice is tearing down all the
systems
and you'll notice the facts don't matter
in any of these cases the adam toledo
shoot was a justifiable shooting by a
police officer adam toledo
was missing for two days in chicago his
mom didn't even call the cops
he was a member of a gang where were his
parents his mom tucking him in
she did not call the cops when he went
missing for two nights he was shooting a
gun
and moving vehicles when the police were
called to the scene he ran from the cops
he had a gun behind him and as he
dropped the gun he was shot
okay then and for her justice is that he
goes home
justice says that george floyd in other
words justice is
the tearing down of all of the systems
because any bad thing that happens can
be attributed to the system so this
wasn't justice
right justice is bad things don't happen
anymore and bad things won't happen
anymore
justified or unjustified bad things will
never happen anymore if you just tear
down the systems
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang